I French bulldogs I have two of them
there's six and seven years old they are
the cow and Bentley and they're great
they're like my kids I love him to death
Bentley unfortunately became paralyzed
it was terrible and he had a grueling
recovery and two surgeries a relapse but
now he's doing great and he's able to
run around like crazy like he always did
although now he looks drunk so it looks
as if I give my Bulldog beer in the
morning you know pretty kind of wobbles
but they're they're great you know
they're wonderful amazing dogs most
affectionate breed I've ever known I
research I know a lot about and the
characteristics of the French Bulldog
seemed that they would suit my
personality in my lifestyle of course my
two French bulldogs these specific
French bulldogs are breed a typical you
know so they're crazy there's just
absolutely crate there like Jack Russell
terriers you know they're incredibly
high energy and crazy and always
demanding attention they're absolutely
hilarious I mean I just there there
there um everything to me i just love
them well i wish i had six you know I'm
trying to talk my partner Dennis since
letting letting me get one more you know
and then maybe one more after that but
they sleep in bed with me I work in bed
as I mentioned before i work in bed on
with my laptop computer with both of the
dogs right there glued to my legs one is
on top of my legs and one is next you
know and if i move positions then they
move you know with me by at all times i
am in physical contact with my two
french bulldogs literally 24 hours a day
they sleep under the covers in the bed
you